[Music]
police were among the few state
employees working in sri lanka on friday
they used water cannon and tear gas to
disperse hundreds of protesters gathered
at barricades sailing off the entrance
to parliament
inside the building in sri jawad
opposition representatives marched into
the speaker's office asking him to order
the police to stop their operation
they also demanded he set a date for a
no-confidence motion they're putting
forward against the government the
government is under increasing pressure
to resign facing a second nationwide
strike in eight days
hospitals railways postal services
schools and ports were disrupted
strictly
this government and dota by rajapaksa
should responsible for this failure in
the sri lanka therefore we don't believe
they can develop this country hereafter
therefore we asking new government new
new leadership new system for sri lanka
that's why all the people
get together for one umbrella
demonstrations and marches like this
have been a common sight in the capital
colombo and around the country
in chile on the northwestern coast
fishermen also took part in the protests
we have more than 15 000 fishing
families in this area we're all helpless
so we'll protest today tomorrow and in
the future the government has admitted
its foreign reserves have fallen to just
50 million u.s dollars leaving it unable
to buy essential food medicine and fuel
cues have stretched for kilometers
around most petrol stations in recent
days
after months of insisting it has things
under control the government has now
approached the international monetary
fund for a bailout
and president gotabe rajapaksa has
replaced his cabinet as calls increased
for him to step down
his new media minister told al jazeera
rajapaksa is making an effort and should
be supported to bring stability
he got into some very powerful
people who in the cabinet some of some
of his own family members of five of
them are out now so with these radical
changes he are trying he's making an
effort
so i think
we are trying to help him
uh he has given us a challenge we are
trying to face that challenge and find
solutions to the people gudegeva says
the new team should be given six months
to a year and a half before elections
are held to decide a way forward
trade unions say the last work stoppage
of this scale was 69 years ago but a
warning they will launch an indefinite
strike if the government does not heed
demands for it to resign mina fernandez
al jazeera colombo